[Music]
white people having dreads is cultural
appropriation strongly agree strongly
disagree answer in the comments below
and suggest a prompt on our kickstarter
i thoroughly enjoy fried chicken you
know i understand the stereotypes about
it and all that kind of stuff but that
chicken thing man the chicken you know
chicken is just not that's just not
something that black people enjoy
you name me one group of people that
don't like a yard
[Music]
kanye west is invited to the cookout
i told you i was leaving you there
they might have got worse let's just be
honest well yeah last time i was a agree
because i was like he's just the crazy
junk uncle but now he's
he's a little too disruptive i don't
want him at my cookout i mean granted
he's got a lot of things he's going
through so i'm not expecting him to
change anything right now but right now
he's just still he needs some time
figure out life then come eat i'm
doubling down again he's misunderstood
people like kanye are creatives and he
uses like creative speech like i don't
think that he's so creative and that his
words are being misinterpreted like he's
making very specific phrases like black
people chose to be slaves that's
completely untrue and in my opinion
that's just unacceptable but i think
that's that's people misunderstanding
what he's saying and let's be real
like
nobody including kanye doesn't think
that like people got in line to get
shackled to be a slave this is part of
the problem the media cut off kind of
like the overall like meaning of what
he's trying to say people were angry
that he was republican or that he was
voting for trump and what he was
basically saying is you're not don't be
a slave to like the democratic party i
think there's an identity politics issue
in the black community you're not
allowed to think freely and he is to me
another member of this of my community
and i want him on my cookout invite him
over your house dude
barbecue yeah kanye west
would you let kanye teach your children
i think i think kanye west is not a bad
person i ain't saying a bad person
he's a bad person nothing to do about
him as a person but i wouldn't let the
grand wizard give my children a history
lesson
dave chappelle
i have
loved ones and friends and family who
are
like part of the queer community and i
have friends who are trans and talking
to them about like the last couple
specials and just sort of like his
comments
in general about trans people
it has kind of rubbed me the wrong way
which is like it sucks because i really
did love chappelle show i loved a lot of
his stand-up specials but like over the
years it's just like okay well now i'm
seeing it through a different lens
because other people are bringing things
to light that i probably wasn't thinking
about when i watched it i'm a big dave
chappelle i love comedy
he was trying to navigate a very very
narrow
channel and i
i think he did it quite well i mean
because
he's a comedian you know they're there
to push the boundaries of funny and at
the same time what you're saying you got
to be careful so i agree with you on
that but after hearing chappelle explain
you just saw the uh he was on stage
after he did the closer yeah he came
back yeah we're not after him i don't
think he had any malice in his heart i
think we need to learn how to
not apologize for people because of
their historical importance just because
i love the chappelle show doesn't mean
i'm gonna stand up for the closer like
it's not always just a joke because it
might be just a joke to you it's not
just a joke to that person who just got
murdered
black people are more homophobic than
other races
so almost say it is i'm an avid golfer
right so majority a lot of my friends
when i play golf with are white and they
say some some stuff too when it comes to
so that's why i was like i got to come
with somewhat disagree but
you know i don't even speak for our
community we are a little rough on the
lgbtq community so
why do you guys think this uh prompt is
asked because there's a lot of rappers
who say homophobic stuff all the time
yeah and the black church
i think religion plays a big part of of
homophobia in like our society today
like but it's not just the black church
america would be better off if only
black people voted
[Music]
i think our votes would pretty much
reflect
what would be good for the outcome of
america even for the lgbtq community
yeah i believe so i believe so i'm not
saying
it's asking things that are just within
our own community that we are we don't
all agree on that's a good question i
think the majority of us will actually
be for
equal rights black people know what it's
like to be discriminated against i think
anytime you have a homogeneous group
that's making decisions you're
inevitably going to have problems so
like i think it might start off with
this idealist you know way of like yes
let's vote for things that are going to
make everybody happy but eventually like
power just corrupts people so if we're
the only ones voting we're going to
start to do stuff that advantages us
especially given our history here
black people can be racist
i think somebody told me about how like
racism exists within uh this space of
power and like you have to look at it in
terms of racism comes from having the
power for your ideals to
actually cause harm to other people or
disadvantage other people and so most of
the time a racist black person doesn't
have enough power to harm somebody that
they're racist against are you saying
there aren't black people who can hire
and fire people
no well i hire inspire people i mean
define i mean power what's power to you
then racism is a specific type of
prejudice
that everyone can be prejudiced can a
chinese person be racist
in china yes about here in america i
think in america it's a it's a
predominantly white rand society so i
think as a racial oppression a chinese
person cannot be racist to black people
in the united states i think they could
be prejudiced to black people i think
they can
i think they can influence individual
black people but let me say this i look
at i look at racism as a system yeah i
think context matters in this situation
here so because when you look at it like
this will you just break can a black
person be racist yes can a black person
be racist in america
no really no think about it how does a
black person being racist in america
benefits a black person
yeah that's my point think about it how
if i want to be racist in america how
can i get ahead that's been i'm set out
to be a black racist but getting ahead
isn't the criteria to be racist but
racism it's that's where it starts at
though bro like it's like one of the
main engines so all right so we're we're
going to use different words what you're
basically saying is that in order to to
be racist you could you could only be
white in the united states i'm just
saying the impact is bigger so the
judgment around what it is none of it's
right but the impact is widely different
the u.s should pay black people
reparations oh yeah the u.s should pay
black people reparations
go
i will say though it's not just black
people uso's a lot more money the u.s
doesn't exist
without
black help african americans hands down
at every stage i'd like to correct it
though i think there should something
should be done for the descendants of
slaves
that's why that's why i was like i think
it has black americans i took it as
black america
because because i feel like my family
just got here in the 70s so like do i
feel like i deserve what a person
deserves whose family is literally
slavery no well the question you asked
was a good question do you deserve i
think yes but how much do you deserve in
comparison to others with with longer
history here that's the that's the next
question why does a recent immigrant
from africa that came maybe 10 years ago
deserve money there is systemic
oppression still happening today so
they're still impacted it may not be the
same degree but they're still impacted
and reparation for me doesn't mean
here's five dollars or here's a million
dollars one individual black person it
means what are we doing to repair
the community that we have
disenfranchised in our society that's
all it means to me yeah i mean anyways i
i think reparations the term to me is is
people look at it as like getting a
check right
and and a check needs to be cut
don't make don't make no don't make no
mistake about that a check need to be
cut because the wealth of this country
was was stolen from our labor bro yeah
so and don't think don't think just
because you're from africa you don't
deserve none of that either because they
did a number on africans as well
police target black men and women
three
two
one
go
you know i
i
like law and order i like safety
and i do think for the most part
a lot of the police
throughout the country
do it to serve their communities um but
you know the last two years has really
showed me that like
you know we have a lot of problems and
it's not you know i was it was emotional
for me as well especially after um
you know george floyd incident but that
wasn't even the only one there's so many
and it got to the point where
you know i started to
really ask myself like is this
you know how can you get law and order
and safety
on and and still respect police but at
the same time like
um
fight for change and it's hard i mean i
don't know what to do
i don't think any of us really
have the solution
it was created to monitor the minority
in the group back in the day it was the
irish it was italians and so
it's ingrained into the system of
policing and that's the problem i think
we have to reframe what policing is now
and until we do that it will always be
targeting people of color because that's
what it was created to do it's it's one
of those things for me like the word the
phrasing of it is police and that's a
big term right that means it's not an
individual person we're talking about
we're talking about institution we're
talking about all the people within that
institution the system the institution
is protecting the individuals who have
target people of color and we see them
doing that because the ones that get
caught in media
it's not the first infraction so that
means there were individuals who were
aware of what happened either being a
partner in the car with them or on those
streets with them or a supervisor or
whoever it may be
who allowed them to go back on the
street in the same manner that they were
before and continue doing the same
things and the institution makes money
from the targeting of black people
if the police don't arrest people prison
can get no customs you got to look at
the prison industrial complex here too
in the u.s that's huge business so and
if you look at
a group of citizens that have been
perceived as
no value having to society or whatever
okay boom we're going to push them we're
going to pipeline them into that system
but also you have to remember that like
almost 20
of murders
is us and like we're the victims of a
lot of crime
right and so
we're also the beneficiaries
of some of the protections that do
happen and so it hurts us to have like
no type of protection or safety as well
there's a there's a there's we're not
saying abolish all forms of protection
right we're saying we need to reframe
what that protection looks like so that
we can feel safe because we don't even
though
people say the statistics are saying
we're safer on the statistics but really
do you feel does the community feel
safer what did you all think about derek
chavin's guilty verdict i feel like it's
still performative in some ways like
cool all right there's that verdict
there's still probably going to be a
video tomorrow of somebody else so it
doesn't feel like it moves the needle
very much when it's just one very high
profile case something needs to change
for those people who are supposed to be
our protectors to actually protect us
and
i do want to say that you said something
about like we're the ones who do the
most crime or something like that or
we're the most victims yeah and it's
like why are we victims all the time why
are you know there being guns put into
our communities at higher levels why are
we getting sentenced for certain
offenses more heavily than other races
like there's prison need customers
exactly and it's customers too it's not
just prisoners
you're saying that you're saying that
we're victims we're getting killed and
robbed and hurt in our we like we're
getting hurt why not not because not
that i think why aren't we going to do
with the prison no no it does it there's
there's research that says impoverished
communities have more crime it's not
because they enjoy crime more it's
because they're impoverished it's
because they need money they need to
survive and so there's a cycle
that leads there's a cycle of prison
which means less education which means
less income which means smaller smaller
money coming to your community which
means less education which means more
crime which means more prison so the
statistics about our community making
crime yes but why is that cycle
happening in our community
i am proud to be black
three
two one go
we went to y'all time nothing's changed
there yeah
right
glad to have you on the same side as
last month
yeah
i feel more proud of our people every
day because it's another day we survived
even just even the slightest
microaggressions that happen to our
community throughout and yet we wake up
and yet we get dressed and yet we go out
and we do it again and again because we
have the hope of a better future of
change and i think that's something to
be very proud of and to never let slide
always be proud of that yeah and i think
the more i see people gaining
traction like and america changing to
where we're able to make moves in ways
that we couldn't before the prouder i
get so you know it might sound silly to
be excited about seeing more black
billionaires or like a black i think
miss america miss usa and miss something
else like all three were black women for
the first time ever i just want to say
for all the people in the comments that
were saying i'm not black i'm black okay
because a lot of people were accusing
me of
basically yeah not being black and i
think it's important to remember that
black is diverse
and that we have different types of hair
different skin tones and so you know
anyways you're not a monolith
not a monolith not a monolith
[Laughter]
i actually spoke all this time yeah you
let it know
let everybody know black and white gotta
let it know black is black yes
you